E aí
[Música]
Oi meu nome é Maria Aparecida consentino
todos me chamam de Maria sua filha de um
coronel do exército e uma dona de casa e
hoje magistrada da violência doméstica e
familiar contra a mulher de Belo
Horizonte uma mulher desperta desperta
para essa triste realidade da nossa
sociedade patriarcado maltrata
inferioriza humilha estupra e até mata
mulheres por todo o globo terrestre
O Despertar significa quando você começa
a enxergar algo que você não enxergava
ter uma visão de uma situação que antes
você não tinha e essa situação é que o
mundo das mulheres é infinitamente mais
difícil que o mundo dos homens e esse
foi o despertar bem meu pai como eu
falei Coronel do exército cheio de
crianças machistas descendente de
italiano aproveita esse momento para
render homenagem a pela saudade que ele
me faz e o amor que eu tenho por ele mas
ele errou muito comigo errou muito na
minha criação eu não fui criada como um
o interesse nenhum de Despertar a minhas
vocações a minhas potencialidades a
preocupação do meu pai era sempre que eu
tivesse casada ele se preocupava sempre
que eu teria que ter um dono é triste
falar isso eu sei que tudo era feito com
muito boa vontade com muito
a intenção ele tinha impressão eu
passava a impressão que ele realmente
ficaria feliz o dia que ele tivesse
casado a sua filha ele poderia ficar
descansado patriarcado faz isso queria
essa falsa visão de inferioridade da
mulher que mulher precisa de um
casamento para ser completa aos 15 anos
eu fazia aula de plástico low cost
costura ao 19 18 anos eu era uma
excelente cozinheira como eu sou até
hoje aos 19 anos eu entrei no Altar
linda com vestido de noiva para si uma
rainha o noivo Militar da AMAN Parecia
um príncipe na saída as espadas dos
colegas não sei que já conheceu já vi um
casamento de militar as túnel de espadas
batem e nós passamos naquele túnel na
saída Chuva de Arroz e
é um casamento dos sonhos do meu pai um
ano depois claro que esse casamento não
poderia dar certo e me separam e eu
decido o que eu quero que gostaria
queria fazer faculdade de direito
gostaria de cursar Faculdade de Direito
em uma grande briga com meu pai porque
ele não queria que eu ficasse no Rio de
Janeiro mas eu consegui e mais engraçado
que eu tinha decidido a minha minha vida
profissional naquele momento eu queria
ser juíza e o mais engraçado foi forma
que eu disse ide minha profissão só vai
ver um filme uma mulher aí entra no
recinto todos se levantam aí eu olhei
aquilo falei eu quero ser isso quero que
todos se levantem quando eu entrar
é óbvio que todos se levantarem naquele
momento eu não sabia que a minha alma já
sabia eu queria ser respeitada como
mulher
e eu queria ser respeitada com mulher
porque estava com guardado em mim dentro
do meu consciente aquelas mensagens
subliminares de inferioridade esse
patriarcado então consegui passar no
concurso não eu entro na faculdade me
formo e passa no concurso com quatro
anos depois papai ficava Radiante Papai
ficou muito surpreso ele falava para as
pessoas todos os lados eu tinha até
vergonha e agora eu entendo porque ele
ficou tão feliz que ele realmente
acreditava aqui a sua filha Mulher não
poderia ter um cargo que destinasse que
decidiria o destino das pessoas né para
ele o minha vida profissional seria para
completar algo para completar a minha
vida de casada e dona de casa e de mãe
papai aprendeu muito comigo e juntos nós
crescemos
É mas eu não saberia disso tudo como eu
sei hoje no meu despertar eu não tivesse
assumido a vara de violência doméstica
contra a mulher
E assumir a salvar e escutar todos os
dias mulheres que sofrem todos os tipos
de agressão dilacerados na sua alma me
causam despertar incrível e eu enxerguei
a mais terrível das verdades que todas
as minhas dores nas constrangimentos
vieram mês patriarcado sabe ter
conhecimento de algo não é a mesma coisa
do que sentir na aula sexta saber que
você que o Brasil tem índices altíssimos
Todos nós sabemos mas quando você começa
a ouvir mulheres todos os dias ali
relatando todos os tipos de dores é
muito triste me ajudou muito no nível
Despertar a cultura do machismo é uma
cultura de inferioridade de menos presa
mulher e não podemos ser mais cúmplices
desse silêncio e dessa discriminação eu
decidi Qual é meu propósito de vida do
propósito de vida é despertar
O Despertar a sociedade mulheres e
homens dessa estrutura patriarcal dessa
estrutura machista que mata aí você vai
me dizer não patriarcado existe isso é
uma bobagem mulheres estão no topo e eu
te respondo que nome se dá aos índices
de violência Pelo Mundo no Brasil conta
se cadáveres nós estamos no quinto lugar
no ranking de 80 países que conta se
cadastre de mulheres que morrem dentro
de um relacionamento um três mulheres
morrem por dia no Brasil praticamente
uma a cada 7:15 mulher cada 15 segundos
uma mulher é espancada no Brasil e a
cada 18 segundos no mundo segundo
relatório da ONU na da ONU 137 mulheres
morrem por dia dentro de um
relacionamento e o significa 58 por
cento das mulheres que morrem por todo o
globo terrestre 4
14 milhões de mulheres estão no comércio
sexual no mundo das 500 empresas mais
top do Brasil apenas 14 por cento dos
cargos são ocupados por mulheres
encontra no Parlamento a culpa nas 16
por cento a luta da mulher é
infinitamente mais difícil que a do
homem sem isso é histórico é milenar o
Velozes Victor Hugo tem uma frase que
diz a história da luta do feminino na
história da humanidade é uma das maiores
tirania que já experimentamos Isso não é
coisa da minha cabeça é um relatório
kinsey de 2011 um estudo feito nos
Estados Unidos que mulheres conseguiram
todas as mulheres conseguiram promoções
com base nos seus resultados no que
produziram e produzido com muito esforço
e suor os homens conseguiram as suas
promoções com base nos seus potenciais
e é você vai dizer que a cultura do
machismo não existe que o patriarcado é
uma bobagem é a minha rotina é ouvir
mulheres dilacerados da sua alma que não
sabem não tem mais vida que perderam-se
no decorrer desse relacionamento o
machismo ensinado dentro das casas
naturalmente meninos e ele não mata sua
mulheres ele mata os homens ele é o
crime os homens também porque de 10
suicídios no Brasil cada dez suicídios
pois são praticados por homens homens
são treinados criados para não expressar
nenhuma emoção que não seja raiva e Ódio
força não pode levar desaforo para casa
omissão ducados para serem os provedores
responsáveis da vida financeira de todos
homens qual é o homem que nunca escutou
o dentro de casa quando criança eu fui
repreendido por um pai ou por uma mãe
seja homem olha esse
o homem não chora isso é muito triste a
cultura do machismo melhor naturalizado
dentro da nossa família nossa sociedade
ensinado dentro das famílias
naturalmente Basta ver a vida de meninas
e meninos o quão diferente é dois irmãos
meninos eles e o mais triste é que eles
são são são Eles assistem famílias paz
ofendendo suas mães e reproduzem esses
comportamentos então o que que a mãe são
xingados dentro das suas famílias são
humilhadas são até agredidas fisicamente
o filho ele faz o que ele vai reproduzir
esse comportamento EA menina entende que
ela merece exatamente essa essa ser
discriminadas é merece migalhas merece
não ser amada por que é esse também
modelo aquela tem dentro de casa
É certo que hoje a a visibilidade sobre
violência doméstica muito maior né hoje
nós temos a internet no meu tempo não
tinha tantas informações como essa hoje
nós temos uma lei que defende a mulher
Lei Maria da Penha eu sou testemunha da
grandiosidade dessa lei essa lei ela
trouxe uma mudança cultural social
política na vida da mulher na vida da
sociedade brasileira ela trouxe essa
discussão em pauta é uma lei que protege
quem puder e fortalece a mulher Consul
medidas protetivas a sociedade precisa
acreditar mas ela é tão boa assim o que
que mulheres continuam morrendo tanto
pelo Brasil e pelo mundo
e eu li uma frase Simone voar que foi
muito forte opressão não seria tão forte
se não tivesse cúmplices entre os
oprimidos está em mulheres precisam
deixar de ser com preciso dos seus
opressores mulheres precisam despertar
mulher desperta não entra um
relacionamento abusivo E quem seria essa
mulher desperta essa mulher desperta é a
mulher que tem reconhecimento do total
do seu poder pessoal tem conhecimento da
sua força da sua beleza da sua
integridade que sabe que não merece nada
além do que felicidade na sua vida não
deixa entrar na sua vida uma pessoa que
vai tratá-la como o migalhas tratá-la e
o fim dela ela sabe que quem entra na
sua vida é uma pessoa para acrescentar
princípios e valores a mulher desperta
uma mulher sábia ela desvia como loba
dos
é que estão por aí E são muitos muitos
que ainda não despertaram mas irão
despertar porque o caminho é esse não
tem mais volta o caminho é da sociedade
despertar para esse abuso desrespeito e
desconsideração com sexo feminino e tem
uma frase que eu gosto muito de usar de
Victor Hugo numa força capaz de mudar
uma ideia cujo tempo tenha chegado A
ideia é essa o tempo é esse Tempo de
Despertar eu estou fazendo a minha parte
com muito afinco eu espero que você faça
sua muito obrigada